muito obrigada por vocês estarem aqui é
um momento assim de grande emoção e
gratidão
na verdade para continuar na educação
fui reinventando a minha prática foi
inventando a história como mulher como
educadora como mãe como amiga
hoje eu tenho muitos amigos aí eu
inventei uma ideia sim de tomar como
base as inspirações de vida de pessoas
que fazem a diferença na minha que às
vezes as pessoas não sabem o quanto isso
fazem diferença
hoje aqui tem várias pessoas que me
inspiram e que eu acho que fazem o
inovar acontecer é uma forma da gente vê
fora da caixa gente inclusive um símbolo
do do óculos pra vocês conhecerem um
pouquinho e através de inovar que foi
bem complicado de iniciar porque é uma
iniciativa que traz um pouco de uma
prática desafiadora dentro da rede
pública a proposta de utilizar uma
educação de qualidade para todos com
recurso já é bem reduzido que república
ainda não consegue aumentar de uma forma
tão é tranquila e ea gente hoje propõe
um grupo não posso falar que essa
inovação inovação individual porque a
inovação em equipe
a gente propõe desde o ciclo básico até
o ensino superior e aí eu digo pessoas
que estão fora da educação uma ação
colaborativa de inovação são práticas
que atraem a a a vivência com a educação
tecnológica
o compartilhamento de idéias e os
projetos de extensão uma mudança na
figura é quando alguns outros
palestrantes estarão aqui hoje é a
proposta de inverter e de aprender junto
e se ainda não está muito claro as
provas foram situações aqui em vários
momentos diferenciados avaliações não o
quanto esse processo ele não é o mais
válido o processo de aprendizagem temos
é de tudo o que a gente passa os erros
né
algumas não sejam assim eu tentei
experimentei e e esse processo de erro e
reconstruir
tudo que a gente está apostando é o que
faz a gente criar soluções então é o meu
papel enquanto educador ele vinha num
marasmo no sistema encaixotado
eu não não me sentia mais capaz de fazer
parte daquele tinha uma grande paixão
pela formação e pela construção do ser
humano através dessas inquietações que
vinham cada vez maior na minha prática
diária eu venho construindo um trajeto
de conhecer novas ferramentas de
utilizar novas ferramentas e de tentar
fazer acertos hoje dormindo muito poucas
em termos de profundidade é eu fui
percebendo que têm papéis diferentes a
gente vai adquirir habilidades
diferentes muitas vezes até de falar por
outro aprofundar a acreditar em você
unir habilidade
então pra continuar na educação a gente
construir um projeto em uma sala de aula
diferenciada tem a cara de garagem
ela está se replicando outros municípios
ela vem pro é prioritariamente aplicada
à educação pública mas a gente tem
exceção de apoio de vários agentes
privados porque eu acho que esse médico
tem inspirações em conjuntos que vale
muito a pena para formação de valores
então a gente vem incentivando ute a
utilização dessas ferramentas para
soluções sempre com contextualizadas com
uma demanda de dificuldade que essa
criança possa que esse jovem possa em
que esse adulto possa educador inclusive
os próprios gestores possam sentir
autores do novo sistema porque esse
sistema e hoje está extremamente carente
ele não tem significado para diversas
épocas diversos grupos
então o que me fez permanecer essa luta
é essa busca de tratar de uma nova forma
à educação de reinventar e o tempo
inteiro tentar trazer parceiros com
colaborações com essa idéia de nova
história então a gente pensa em
linguagem pensamento computacional em
arte né
eles falam que eu sou muito descolada
o desenrolar das que foi desenrolada que
eu ouvi a última característica que é a
primeira e por quantas vezes de relutar
um pouco com as regras e com os sistemas
não quero não se fazem necessário mas eu
entendo que é importante que a gente
prova que é capaz de a agregar e de
contribuir com o outro de uma forma
inovadora de uma forma mais colaborativa
é a ponta e inovação ela se torna
coletiva ela se torna de todos é uma
prática que todo mundo pode mesmo dentro
de um sistema aprovado aquele sistema
pode ser reinventado ele não tivesse tão
burocrático então impedir dor para que
todos tenham acesso então hoje minha
busca enquanto educador é continuar numa
prática que permita essa amplitude daí
tornar isso significativo para todos nós
o educador ficar muito frustrado se a
gente for analisar são muitas horas
dentro de sala e aí você tem uma turma
você tem 25 pessoas não te querendo você
tem duas turmas de manhã cedo em 50
pessoas não te querendo se você tem
cinco turmas você tem muitas pessoas não
te querendo num dia só
isso causa muita frustração se repete
semanalmente diariamente mensalmente ao
longo de muitos anos o seu camarada bem
frustrado é que você não é querido e aí
você planeja não tem uma etapa aqui sim
o tempo também usar muito mas nem as
etapas e planeja experimenta não chega
ninguém quer isso acontece porque não
tem nenhum tipo de afeto e não tem
relação naquele processo
então a partir do momento que eu me vi
capaz de fazer uma nova história
me senti querido talvez pode fazer com
que tudo que ele fosse planejado fosse
coletivo para que todos nós quiséssemos
construir junto
isso traz uma sensação de autoria e se
eu sou tô eu cuido eu faço de forma
voluntária
às vezes eu cobro de uma outra forma o
meu retorno eu começa a ter uma parceria
de trabalho de inventos enfim informados
coletivos
então assim a gente vai construindo
novas relações com um saber com aprender
com a inovação é essa é a maneira que o
encontro hoje de permanecer na educação
como professora
essa é a forma que me faz ficar fora da
caixa e assim recebo muitas vezes
críticas elogios de fora da casa todo
mundo dessa frase boa não
a gente é muito louca muito maluca
totalmente fora da caixinha de vela é
bem fora da caixa inovador depende em
mais 21 nações que não são tão positivas
assim mas é isso que me faz permanecer
ainda nesse lugar com muito amor com
muito afeto e com muito desejo de fazer
a diferença
foi através da tecnologia assistido que
eu cheguei na programação e na robótica
foi um percurso de individual na minha
formação porque eu queria uma solução
para afetar o público que eu tinha
selecionado na época para trabalhar e me
provocou inúmeras é é é é e inquietações
e eu busquei isso busca ao longo desse
meu tempo não sei quantos e quantos
amigos e parceiros e talvez desconfiados
permanecem conosco nessa busca
mas inovar é pra gente não sabia que
usava a frase quem viveu comigo isso vai
entender
inovar é aprender ea gente eu venho
provocar a vocês que você continue
inovando isso já é uma forma de novação
estar aqui nesse tipo de imóvel que
talvez nem todos confiaram durant foi
muito tempo e que vocês é busquem essa
certeza numa carreira que talvez não
seja o diploma que vai fazer nem
reconhecimento nem a remuneração que vai
fazer vocês saírem satisfeitos é não
talvez não seja um robô que vai ser
solucionar o problema eu inclusive
aposto que quanto mais jogos a gente tem
já está tudo batizado mais humanos é a
gente tem que buscar se então que
consiga inovar que vocês estejam junto
um todos esses educadores que toparam
está aqui com esses jovens com essas
famílias
a gente não tem um público aqui muito é
criterioso né a idéia é que todas as
gerações
sejam afetadas que vocês possam
participar cada vez mais iniciativas
como essa de compartilhamento de
inovação
agradeço todos muito obrigada revistam
de pagas